hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba John we
are going to watch today another patron
video request one of our reward tiers as
we mentioned before whatever video
request we must definitely cover on the
youtubes yes it's another reaction today
and this one comes from Tyler Hague who
we're gonna be doing a Google hangout
with again very soon and dude we've
already given you a shout out earlier
we're gonna cover this video so we have
to give a shout out to someone else
sorry if that upsets you Tyler will
apologize on the Hangout sure I thought
it will be perfect to shout out a man
named John Mini this guy lives in New
York been married for not that long of a
time but I think he's perfect to shout
out because if there's one guy on
patreon who could possibly be a meth
dealer it's definitely John MIDI that's
where he gets the money to support us I
think he's on meth when we talk with him
probably I mean he's got that kind of
you know jittery vibe yeah it's a great
look yeah yeah yeah yeah but hey man
whatever you got to do to take care of
it your new marriage or your family you
have going on that's why we like Walter
White and that's why we also like John
Minnie who doesn't watch television so
he's probably not even watching this
video we could say whatever we want but
we won't [ __ ] one - what's up guys it's
Aaron Paul and I want you to come break
bad with me yeah [ __ ] I heard that
right it's been ten years since breaking
bathroom mirror and to celebrate I'm
teaming up with omae's to fly one winner
and a friend out to cook in the RV right
here in Los Angeles we're gonna cook
cement or breakfast what yeah okay
yeah we'll probably breakfast show you
but that might be like I thought I would
give you a quick tour of our past and
future kitchen
as an agent all in the past few years no
it's just like I remember no tours
researching a role movie what's um
what's with this what's going on give
you a chance to cook in the RV with me
wait a minute
Breaking Bad is gonna be rebooted just
like Roseanne without the racism I've
moved on you yeah no you I there is a
hot plate mm-hmm here is that your hot
plate I bought it for the charity cook
thing
it's an induction cooker by the way yeah
science [ __ ] remember that you remember
yeah no I
oh you were so good as Jesse you know we
really ought to think about bringing the
show back just saying just an actor
who's broken now can't get over the fact
that his show has been finished for five
years and so I'm living in an RV and
using a bucket as a toilet yeah whatever
Oh
it's like a month in there oh my god no
[Music]
you're hot and this is the RV from
Breaking Bad uh-huh
welcome to Sony Studios now if you guys
just want to head that way to the studio
gift shop I'll meet you there in just
one second right over there thank you
Aaron what the hell are you doing what
what is all this why have you leading
the tour you work here begging me for a
job the other day because you only
wanted to be around the RV again loser
well now what are you do you argue Oh
leash the show ended five years ago get
over it you know put on some clothes
and you put on your uniform okay Stu
come on don't make me wonder what did
you just call me
hmm say my name
[Music]
hard to kill her
so bad off right we got the RV hot plate
I've got the bucket that we could poop
in we still got our internet friends
uh-huh
come on and why don't you tell them
about the charity event
come on for a chance to come cook with
Brian me in the Breaking Bad army go to
omae's dot-com slash Breaking Bad and
all the money raised will go to us so we
can buy new stuff oh no no no National
Center for Missing and Exploited yeah so
maybe you can go in and you can be great
really great
please please will let you touch our
Emmys you can shoot in the bucket
[Music]
oh man and yeah today I so I need so
love that with every bit of my my heart
therapy Breaking Bad is the only drama I
have seen from beginning to end
twice I've never reached a drama before
this literally as I'm watching this made
me go alright I need to worry watch
breaking is actually really really made
me miss that show man I've seen like the
amazed bits before Murr there's like a
dodge ball one that was like funny they
don't always go all out on these but
yeah this was the most I liked that they
kept it as that this is Aaron Paul of
Bryan Cranston and I love the concept of
the sketch yeah which is not true
actually yeah Interpol's worked quite a
bit and so as Bryan Cranston has worked
quite a lot - yeah I mean Bryan Cranston
jumped into movies and Aaron Paul is
like three TV show yeah and what I love
so much about this sketch is just how
much they're willing to make fun of
themselves here you really go all out oh
yeah it wasn't like yeah we don't really
want to do this and we're making fun of
what we're doing they were committed to
this joke if you're seeing their acting
chops here they're a chemistry it's like
toy different dynamics that Walter White
and Jesse but it's the chemistry of
these two performers that can work off
each other so well that is still present
in this sketch and I think it's what
makes it such a delight is that even
though they're playing just satire
versions of themselves it's so
delightful because I chemistry it's
still present yeah yeah yeah it really
makes you want to see them together
regardless of yeah that means as a
sketch conceptually it's cute but it's
so much more than that when you see it
come to life because yeah they're both
just so committed to it yeah it really
makes you wish that we could enter and
win yeah you know again like just props
to them for going for this and for
really being open to it because I don't
think everybody would be willing and
they just liked it so yeah most people
would have asked this I think yeah yeah
like I whatever this is just some silly
thing they really did this bit they were
areas in this they were hilarious yeah
stuff like this really makes me think
the breaking bad for them for the people
who got to work on it probably was as
special of an experience as it is for
all of us who loved it I mean obviously
in a different way but it seems like
there is something really special about
that team in that show you've been
exemplified in wacky little things like
this yeah yeah just from this sketch
they don't seem to have any bit of
distaste for you know I'm sure when
people see them they're associated with
the show so much but it feels like
there's a love for it yeah and yeah this
this amaze bit was like I do want to
come I love this joke he's been living
in the RV and then the twist that Aaron
Paul's kept getting more self-aware as
he kept going he's like yeah like every
little piece is self-aware and sometimes
I can get obnoxious but this I thought
that was actually really well yeah it's
like they're constantly kind of breaking
the fourth wall with that this made me
very happy I was genuinely like watching
this video yeah put a smile on my face
and I mean it always warms my heart to
see folks willing to do this for such
worthy causes too yeah because they're
supporting what sound like two really
great charities and that's the best
reason to do some wacky like this in the
first place yes the way this was written
was really smart this could have been
like cheap jokes but the level of
self-awareness never went away even with
the cameras recording dr. holeczek we're
recording right now yeah I feel like
sometimes these sketches they would
forget to acknowledge the fact that
they're recording him like Aaron Paul
never lost that awareness that was great
I was so happy with that video man well
done and well keep the request really
yeah seriously thanks for the request
I'm so happy here and Paul Bryan
Cranston me like just this video alone
his work I know I'm just gonna watch it
again right yeah like when I'm feeling
blue I'm gonna put this on like how can
you be a Breaking Bad fan and then watch
this and not want to participate because
you become like them you're like could
we get the show back please he said he
doesn't think Walt's dead so that's true
you know all right guys well the
Breaking Bad did have a revival would
you care what do you think it should I
don't think
or do you prefer the Colombian version
do you think they should do a comedy
together you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
about the subscribe buttons are broken
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage you love to have you become a
patronage act today